let's get some insight on today's events
on Capitol Hill from Ohio congressman
Jim Jordan the ranking Republican on the
House Oversight Committee thank you for
being here congressman I want to get
your thoughts on today's hearing what's
your takeaway
I think the first takeaway is Michael
Cohen's delusional he actually said in
the hearing that he Michael Cohen is the
one who launched the Trump presidential
campaign because he started some website
back in 2011 so again I don't think you
can trust anything he says he actually
argued disagreed with what the Southern
District of New York prosecutor said
when they said in their sentencing memo
that he was wanting to get a job in the
White House he says no I did and I
didn't want a job in the White House so
when you're disagreeing with the
prosecutors to a crime you plague the
guys who you pled guilty to a crime and
saying you're the guy who launched the
presidential campaign I don't know that
you can take much of what he says had
any real value what about the specifics
on the hush payments as he called them
the 11:00 payments to him the checks
that he brought and said into into the
record what was your take on that
well first of all remember Brett there
was no new evidence here because if
there was any new evidence the
prosecutors wouldn't have allowed it to
be heard in an open set they would be
they would be part of an ongoing
investigation so there was nothing new
here and Michael Cohen can't have it
every way he wants on one hand he said
it was my dream job I was the
president's personal lawyer and then on
the other hand he says but I wasn't
giving any payments in the reform in the
form of a retainer over the time period
that I was actually his personal lawyer
so again I don't think you can believe
much what this guy says what I do think
was going on today is I think this was
the first step in the Democrats crazy
impeachment plans understand this bread
last week Tom Styer mega donor for the
Democrats was in Jerry Nadler SH
district organizing a town hall meeting
to persuade mr. Nadler to go ahead and
move ahead with impeachment two nights
ago Tom Styer was in Baltimore in
chairman Cummings district organizing a
town hall encouraging his constituents
to push chairman Cummings to move ahead
with impeachment that's what this thing
was about today the crazy impeachment
plans of the Democrats you know former
New Jersey Governor Chris Christie
watched the hearing
today former Trump confidante obviously
here's what he had to say about the
Republican question I think the
interesting thing is that there hasn't
been one Republican yet whose jaren
tried to defend the president on the
substance and I think that's something
that should be concerning to the White
House
why are no Republicans standing up and
defending the president on the substance
and and that's either a failure of those
Republicans on the hill or a failure of
the White House to have a unified
strategy with them they knew what was
coming with Michael Cohen your reaction
that Michael Cohen can be trusted the
Democrats first announced witness of
this Congress is a guy who is going to
prison will be a federal inmate in two
months for lying to Congress so I mean
come on we did have actually members do
did defend and dig into some of the
issues I think in particular
congressman Massie did when he
questioned mr. Cohen about if you made
this made this payment and didn't even
know whether it was legal or not what
kind of what kind of lawyer are you so
we did have some members dig into those
issues but the bottom line is how can
you trust anything this individual has
to say when he repeatedly said that he
could not talk about certain things
because they are under investigation by
the Southern District of New York is
that not a red flag to the Trump
administration to the president we don't
know what he's referring to Brett maybe
he's referring to the special counsel we
don't know what he's referring to we
don't know we didn't get to get into
some of these questions we don't know
what this Southern District of New York
or the special counsel's office told him
relative to what he couldn't and
couldn't say in today's hearing and
remember mr. Cummings said the scope was
so limited
mr. Cummings said just things that he
felt that members should be able to ask
about frankly I think they were designed
to be things that only mr. Cummings
thought were going to be embarrassing to
the president so we don't know what that
means we'll have to just wait and see
all right but what about the specifics I
mean I understand all of your points
about credibility I understand all of
the things about undermining his
veracity he is a flawed flawed witness
but what about the substance I mean the
president writing a check to him while
president for these payments these 11
payments
that he says were to pay off stormy
Daniels and the other woman right that
is that not true
Bret Michael Cohen said he was the
personal lawyer for the president he was
there was a retainer arrangement where
he was paid these installments these
payments over the course of the time he
was the personal lawyer for the
president and the Trump Organization I
don't think that's unusual my guess is
there's all kinds of companies all kinds
of individuals who have a similar type
of relationship that's what was brought
up today and again where was the new
news I there wasn't any new news here
and if there was any new evidence no
prosecutor would allow it to be heard
today in an open hearing like this in
Congress well there were some things
that were under oath that perked some
years because you had him saying he did
never he never went to Prague there he
doesn't believe or doesn't hadn't heard
of anything about Russia collusion there
are some things that Republicans would
say hey we are wrong with that but you
said his credibility is shot right well
every once in a while you'll get some
truth from some people we saw it last
week right and he McCabe's a guy who
lied three times under oath and is under
investigation but he did say one thing
in the last couple weeks on his book
tour he's the third person who was told
as rod Rosen Stein was serious about
wearing a wire and invoking the 25th
amendment when you're the third person
I've heard it from other people we've
deposed that's probably some one thing
and Andy McCabe statements inaccurate so
maybe Michael Cohen did say a few things
that were accurate one of those of
course was he's never been to Prague
which again the Democrats didn't want to
focus on that because remember that goes
right to the heart of all this the
dossier was the key the Clinton campaign
paid Perkins cuy who hired Glenn Simpson
who hired the foreigner Christopher
steel to put together the fake dossier
which the FBI use to go get the warrant
to spy on Trump's campaign and then when
that whole scheme fell apart because the
American people elected Donald Trump
president then they come with this plan
the Lanny Davis choreographed hearing
with Michael Cohen
their star witness who was going to
prison in two months for lying that's
what took place today I'd have hearing I
have two more quick questions one you
think that the president is there's no
fault here he has nothing to worry about
I don't there was no new news
I think is one of my colleagues said no
new news but some fake news so I don't
think there's anything here there's no
second do you think the Democrats had a
choice whether to hold this hearing
today well wait until the president got
back on us saw well they should have
waited that's that's for sure and
frankly they should have
I think honored the request that
congressman meadows and I had to the
Chairman which is why not bring rod
Rosen Stein in rod Rose assigns his
Deputy Attorney General oversees the
Southern District of New York over solve
the special counsel until just a couple
months ago rod Rose assigned what we
know we've heard in the last couple
weeks it'd have been nice to have both
of them sitting side by side so we could
get the real story the full story that
had been nice instead of a guy who's got
a 30 minute opening statement a guy who
again is going to prison for lying to
Congress congressman we appreciate your
time we'll follow all the developments
Thanks